foreign
let's run out to the 512 in Austin Texas
and talk to Ali what's up Ally
hey it's awesome to talk to you I uh
have been to all of your shows and I'm
totally loving it I'm totally nervous
about the topic but I'm not nervous
about talking to you so awesome like
you're an older brother at this point
that is the nicest thing it's pretty
heavy that's the nicest thing somebody
has said to me in a long time especially
because my show team thinks that wearing
chain wallets is stupid and I disagree
so thank you well I'm gonna vote with
them on this one but everything else
your life is cool big brother you're
from Austin which is basically uh
Portland of the South I know I'm
supposed to be okay with it but we're
into illness together but fair enough
all right so what's up Ali let's do it
okay so um I wrote out my little preface
in question and then I'm just gonna
really live organically in this
conversation because I'm super nervous
about the topic like I said cool let's
do it um let's do it I have a tendency
to ignore red flags and focus on
people's potential
um so I have committed to following your
advice whatever you tell me on the show
like you could tell me to do the chicken
dance on the top of my car at HEB and
I'm gonna do it okay you need to know
100 that's going to be in the things I
tell you
okay well I'm gonna start practicing all
right
do me a favor before you do the question
will you do me a huge favor
I want you to take as deep a breath as
humanly possible
take it and hold it okay ready one two
take it
hold it one two and then let it out
[Music]
all right here's my promise with you
okay
I am hearing you that you're nervous to
talk about what you're about to talk
about and um here's my promise
my promise is whatever you say I'm gonna
I'm gonna be with you okay
it's a hundred percent my problem no
weird
I got it I got it and I I know that's
heavy but I want you to know that you're
not going to endure this heaviness by
yourself cool
awesome okay so go for it I'm here
so the heart of my question is
husband to feel less Shame about his
sexuality
and I say that because like for years my
closest friends have all asked me like
hey is he like bisexual is he you know
questioning things and I never really
gave it much thought
but you know we've been married for you
know seven years now and over the last
few years it's just kind of like
reared its head a little bit more and
come to maybe be like it could be a real
issue
um without getting too graphic like he
has fetishes that I'm uncomfortable with
things that he enjoys and wants to do
that I don't
um and when we fight or we're
emotionally distanced which does happen
a lot he buys toys to satisfy his own
needs and then he hides it from me
and when I inevitably find out he has a
lot of Shame and embarrassment and he
ends up turning that around onto me and
getting mad at me and saying it's my
fault that he does it or that he has to
hide it or that I caused it in the first
place we were fighting and he had to do
it and um I think that really the heart
of the issue and a lot of why we fight a
lot is that I think he does struggle
with his own sexuality but I think he
feels shame in talking about it and my
question is how do I become how do I
help him see that I'm a safe space to
talk about that
and that that doesn't change that I love
him sure uh thank you for your I mean
you laid that out really beautifully so
thank you for that
um can I ask him some
probing questions
absolutely okay
um
question number one is besides
particular sex acts that he enjoys that
you're not into
and besides his
[Music]
um
going to get sex toys and to assumingly
masturbate himself right take care of
himself in any number of ways
um
that's a very limited scope for for why
you would think I think my husband's gay
I think my husband's bisexual or I think
my husband's not attracted to me
whatever
whatever's there that sense of Shame
paint me a fuller picture here
he does have a really deep appreciation
of like the human body I guess you could
say like all human bodies and like he
comments in a different way than I hear
most men comment when he sees them a guy
who's really ripped or you know he'll
point out attractive men probably more
often than attractive women
he like makes like certain friends on
social media that he just really keeps
track of that are also like or they are
gay and he seems to be drawn to them and
really seek their like when they tell
him he's attractive that's like a really
big sense of Pride for him and like he
goes kind of looking for that from that
population if that makes sense yeah
absolutely so I'm just seeking
affirmation absolutely so
um and by the way everybody listening to
the show seeks affirmation from
somewhere or for multiple places right
yeah
so
there's two con there's there's there's
two directional challenges here
directional challenge number one is
you have I'm assuming tell me if I'm
wrong you have shame
that somehow you're an unsafe place for
the man that you love to land true or
false
true
how long has that been going on in in in
basically the bigger question is how
long has he been keeping secrets from
you
that you were on knowing he doesn't know
this but you're carrying the weight of
those secrets too how long has that been
happening your whole marriage forever
yeah pretty much and and it like I said
I'm really good at ignoring red flags
and seeing potential so in the beginning
when it would happen I was just like
well she just needs to know that I love
and support him and I just need to love
him through this and then he'll open up
and trust me with the truth and then it
was just like he kept lying about things
and and it's not just sex things that he
would lie about there's other things
that he like parts of his identity he
tries to keep hidden from me and so my
I've always really from the beginning
just been like well if I just keep
trying then he'll be open with me and
that hasn't worked out great so one of
the things get that gets lost in the
gender conversation by the way I've had
this conversation I can't I can't even
count so I want you to know you're not
alone okay
um
that gets lost in in the gender
conversation is uh it's a very delicate
thing because
there's a ton of Shame and there's also
a ton of if the wrong person finds out
you are kicked out of your home you're
kicked out of your religious group
you're kicked out of your school I mean
you're like there's a true penalty to be
paid right right and often kids that
recognize they are different especially
when it comes to who they're attracted
to when they're young
um they learn really quick to shut up
about that and they wrestle with that
and they have been mining themselves in
their community and what's okay and who
loves me and who's safe
for years right and so
um
it's easy for you to go I all of this
rests on me and I'm also going to
challenge the other side of the equation
he got married
to you
he looked you in the eye and said you
and I are ride or die till the end of
time
and then maybe even beyond that if you
believe in the right
um uh romance novel right like we're in
this thing
and so there is a price to be paid on
both sides one you better not say
anything and I attached myself to
somebody that I said I was going to be
connected to intimately not just
sexually but spiritually right I'm gonna
they're gonna know me I'm gonna know
them because we're we're one
forever and so you carry the burden too
and we have been we have been separated
and we actually just got back together
and a big part of it was because of the
hiding and the lies and but my bigger
problem with the hiding in lies is that
he makes it sound like it's my fault he
turns it around and blames me so then I
feel like I'm going crazy I question
reality like yes it's gaslighting and
it's clearly happened it's gasoline it
is and and he he learned that from mom
who's you know the shame and whatever
but I think he wants to be better but he
doesn't know how and when he's tried
therapy in the past I think even in
therapy it's like so much shame that he
can't be him true his true self and
really be vulnerable with a counselor
so why'd you go back you know can you go
back because let's let's put sexuality
and gender aside you're married to
someone who lies to you to your face and
has for years
and my guess is uh is there
infidelity involved that you know of
no are you positive specific right no
I'm not and I will be honest and say
that I have occasionally gone and gotten
myself tested so that tells me you're
being a very Commerce koi on the on the
call there's something in your gut that
says whoa
is there pornography involved
oh tons and and in the beginning like
our sex like
five times a day every day for years
and then when it started to dwindle off
I thought something was wrong with me
but that's when like the porn started
getting to be a really big issue and he
was more interested in that than in
having sex with me and so you know the
toys and it just snowballed so I I'll
say that I went back to him because I do
love him and I didn't have potential in
him I see what his mom broke in him and
you can't fix that oh am I kidding
emotional yeah no no no of course you
are you love this man and you're hurting
yeah but you can't fix what mom broke
right you can hold his hand I want to be
a safe landing place and I don't know
how to do that I know but he hasn't
chosen you as that place
and that's one of the hardest things I
can say out loud to somebody in your
situation I'm sorry but it's the truth
he hasn't chosen you
yeah you're right and you spent the last
X number of years
sacrificing your own intimate connection
sacrificing your own romantic
relationship with him sacrificing your
marriage and then deeper than that your
own value yeah
yeah because you were once I see that I
feel like I'm withering away I feel like
I'm not the same person who I was hold
on you are withering away
and this is the
man I don't cause a bunch of drama on
this show but this is where the gender
Converse I mean the not the gender but
the sexuality conversation
gets so blown up it becomes so nuclear
then the dishonesty and the pornography
and the potential
um infidelity
all gets wrapped up in this other
conversation it's not
I think I excused the dishonesty as I
just feel bad for his shame and I you
know I want to believe he hasn't cheated
on me I want to believe all of these
things but you don't but you don't when
I catch him when I catch like he he
bought us away and I find out
there's so much embarrassment he can't
like we can't have a conversation we can
talk about so many things in our sex
life when we have conversation but about
that he shuts down and he won't talk to
me and he's just like oh it's fine I
just fell off the wagon it is what it is
I'm gonna get back on the wagon and I
won't do it again
in a safe relationship there's no wagon
to get on and off of
there's a conversation to be had
right and I I I'm gonna go as far to say
if people have are into weird things or
into weird things and you you talk about
that with your spouse right you talk
about that with your partner you have
that conversation
but he hasn't chosen you
and at some point you said you feel like
you withering away I'm hearing it on
this call
you're like one of those movies where
there's a ghost that comes back and then
they start the time starts running out
and they start getting thinner and
thinner that's what's happening to you
and at least right now it's not because
he might be gay or might not be gay or
might be experimenting or might be
bisexual that's not it it's that you are
married to someone who's lying to you
you're married to someone who is more
into pornography than is to you
who can't who who is not reciprocating
how much of themselves they're putting
on the table for the sake of this
marriage
absolutely and my closest friends have
said that that this is not a
you know equal effort marriage not even
close
and let's say he I in the same way that
he saw potential you saw potential in
him he saw potential in you maybe she's
going to be the one that helps me
because I don't want that whatever the
conversation he's had in his soul for
however many years
and maybe his mom beat him up so bad
emotionally right all those things can
be true
and what he is carrying is so heavy
that at this point he has chosen to not
set it down because he doesn't know how
yeah fine he can do that and you don't
have to be a part of that
both of those things are true his pain
is very real
what he's working through alone I if he
was here I would want to hug him and not
let go
yeah and
I would have to be willing to hit for
him to say I don't want to hug you I
don't know you
and I know that he loves me I know that
he chose to marry me because he loves me
I I know that it's not like he's only
into men and he's not interested in me I
know that he loves me that he thinks I'm
attractive and but I just think there's
such a broken side of him that yeah
you're right I'm just not the one that
he wants to share it with
and the choosing reality is how you're
going to live out of that truth
which is what do I just keep being numb
like I have no
because the other end of that is you die
spiritually emotionally relationally and
then eventually you die die
yeah and I'm definitely not being the
best mom that I can to my kids and
how many kids do you have like you have
kids together
we don't have kids together no how many
kids do you have
I have four
are they are they a ringside seat to all
this
yeah
um some of my kids are grown and out of
the house
I had kids when I was really young but
it hit like they saw it and they they're
very protective of mom and you know they
have been saying for a long time that
this isn't a healthy situation
but I guess I just wanted to make it
happen
is there some
commitment you made to yourself
that what happened in your first
relationship was never going to happen
again
yeah I promised myself that I would
never not be someone's priority and that
I would never get divorced again and so
I don't know what to do when the two
things don't work together yeah you made
yourself you know what I mean a promise
that yeah yeah way to go painted myself
into a corner yeah you really did and
you that's a hard corner to paint
yourself into because you painted you
into it not somebody else right yeah
yeah
um like I want to have all these
standards for myself and these
boundaries and I want to be like my
partner is going to respect me and
appreciate me and value me and make me
they're equal and we're going to be true
partners and but then I just allow
little behaviors
so undermine that
these are not little behaviors
yeah these are massive fractures in a
trusting loving relationship
period that's true but it starts small
it does yeah it does but these are
massive
yeah you're right you're massive
and this is a heteronormative
relationship this is a gay relationship
this is in all relationships you got to
tell the truth
you got to be a person of fidelity
you can't hold these black hole secrets
from somebody because when you say I do
they take on those secrets with you
yeah they just yeah they do to the point
where where he had an incident one time
and he had to hug something removed from
his body and I took the blame for it I
showed up at the hospital and I said it
was me I did it and took that shame from
him because I hold that black hole but I
don't think he does the same for me I
know he doesn't because you wouldn't be
on this call
and so one of the you made yourselves a
bunch of pro you made yourself a bunch
of promises that relied on somebody
else's fidelity
and I'm of the opinion like um in faith
circles they talk a lot about like you
know
infidelity is about who you sleep with
it's not sleeping with somebody that is
not you're not married to I think you
can cheat on somebody on a you know with
your work you can cheat on somebody with
your golf course you can cheat on
somebody by withholding you can with
that neglect right you can cheat on
somebody
um by
vacuuming up all of your internal
turmoil and then when somebody says hey
are you okay you just blast them with it
or the analogy I use is you carry bricks
around in your own backpack and the
moment somebody says whoa whoa whoa you
smash them with your bricks your pain I
[Music]
every time you say hey what is this bam
yeah so I think your path forward is is
is is pretty straightforward pretty
simple
step number one is you make a decision
on what love and respect
you're going to accept or not accept
number two y'all had a trial separation
you move back in
you wouldn't be calling me if that moved
back in was just smooth as silk it
hasn't been has it
no not at all
and so
I think it's time for a very direct hard
conversation which is the following you
might want to write him a letter because
it doesn't sound like he can hear it
sounds like he goes to war with you and
you bring something up or you might want
to write a letter and read it to him
but you have to have a state of the
union conversation which is
I committed to you and I said I do I'm
all in
but part of that commitment part of that
Fidelity meant no lies
no deception
no bringing other people into our bed
whether on TV or whether in person
that these big Mega secrets that are
dragging the entire home down that I
promised I would share with you I have
to at least know what we're fighting
together
and if you don't trust me enough to be a
safe place then you are choosing with
that lack of trust to say you're not my
person
and you are opting out of this this
Unity this one
and I think you started the call with
saying I will love him till the end of
time I'm with him
he's just not with you
and I think the ball is in his his court
as to whether he says okay I'm all in
I will tell you the truth I'll tell you
what I struggle with I'll tell you where
my shame lies and that will be something
you all work through together moving
forward
but I said this earlier you can't fix
what his mama did
and you can't carry Co carry his
shame if he won't let you
and you can't love him through the hurt
he's experiencing which I know he is
because he won't let you know what the
secrets are
and I know that feels so so so lonely
Ellie I'm sorry
he's really lucky to have you in his
life and my hope is that he takes this
moment when you say hey this is my line
this is my line
but I want you to when you when you
state your boundaries I want you to be
very clear about this
if he walks away from your boundary he
walks away you didn't fail your marriage
you didn't crash your marriage you
didn't choose to fill in the blank again
he looked at you and said yeah I can't
go there
I can only go this far in my trust I can
only go this far in my love I can only
go this far in my commitment but there's
a line there
and you're not it
I can't cross it for you
and then you'll have to live in that
reality
here's my promise Ally I'll walk with
you every step of the way
man I'm sorry this is heavy